[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce numéro de page
consacrée au premier tour des
législatives pour en parler armé le bras
show pas bonjour moi je sept points sur
deux sur ceux politiques
et voilà vous avez suivi vous suivez
comme ça des élections avec passion et
patience ça suppose je suis pas
vers un exil bourges où vous êtes maître
de conférences de sciences de gestion à
l'université paris saclay et vous êtes
la co créatrice avec avec votre brille
d'ailleurs et et collègues et deux du
site
élections scop est alors le site et
discussions au scope fait des prévisions
sur les votes mais qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les sous d'argent c'est un modèle
économétrique qui mêle des explications
économiques et politiques alors je
rappelle qu'en janvier dernier vous
aviez donné le résultat exact des
élections présidentielles à un moment où
zemmour était encore dans les sondages
le tréou et
vous avez fait un modèle sur sur les
élections présidentielles dans lequel
dont l'une des conclusions on verra si
si elle est vraie ou pas ce genre
législatives dont serait qu'il n'y
aurait pas de majorité absolue pour les
pour les maquereaux distincts et que
peut-être l air pourrait jouer le rôle
de parti charnière on attend on attend
laurent bazin oui bonjour bonjour
patrice vous êtes maire-adjoint
d'elancourt vous êtes le vice-président
de saint quentin en yvelines le
président de de tv 78 et le porte parole
de vie des it all our souls nous sommes
toujours là nous sommes toujours
présents absolument aux jeux pression
pour être à 6 6 2 en raison surtout en
orbite à l'initiative de ne jamais la
tendance réelle la puissance d'un parti
politique il dit que la banderille
bonjour vous êtes tous vous êtes
journaliste à télé 78 t on verra avec
vous ouvre un point évidemment sur les
résultats dans ce dans ce département on
va commencer peut-être par le premier
thème parce que c'est un thème important
peut-être le plus important fonds de
cette élection vous nous direz c'est
celui de l'abstention
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une abstention
en hausse par rapport à 2010 est il y a
si on regarde pas assez dans les moins
de 30 ans je crois que ça va jusqu'à 70%
d'abstention c'est absolument énorme
je voulais mode et peut-être armelle
est-ce que c'est grave
oui c'est grave c'est grave c'est un
problème de démocratie
il faut tout de même relativiser ce qui
est effectivement une nouveauté c'est à
dire que jamais il ya eu autant
d'abstention mais seulement un point de
plus qu'aux législatives de 2010 est et
il faut noter que depuis 1993
l'abstention augmente régulièrement elle
était d'environ 35% 93 et 2002 va
véritablement est une charnière quand on
va inverser le calendrier entre la
présidentielle et les élections
législatives où les élections
législatives ont désormais lieu après la
présidentielle et donne jusqu ici une
majorité absolue à tous au parti qui a
gagné les lits qui a gagné l'élection
donc c'est la primauté sa annonce la
primauté de l'élection présidentielle
sur toutes les autres élections
évidemment et il ya plus de votants aux
élections présidentielles et après les
gens considèrent que c'est fait on
s'intéressera surtout qu'on n'arrête pas
de répéter
7e tandis que m l'élection
législative va suivre effectivement
complètement les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
donc effectivement ça peut être une des
explications
en ce qui concerne la france de la
désaffection puisque on se dit bon la
partie la partie est jouée j'ajoute
simplement que attention on nous parlons
de la france mais cette désaffection et
cette abstention croissante est valable
pour toutes les démocraties européennes
un peu différents états unis aux états
unis
traditionnellement il ya quand même
relativement peu de votants
dans les élections au nom notamment aux
élections présidentielles non il ya une
50% d'abstention aux canons à peu près
c'était véritablement le cas tous les
derniers temps mais jusqu'à il ya peu de
temps quand
l'enjeu est vif ça augmente et que ça
véritablement augmenté aux états unis ce
qui fait que l'abstention est dans
l'immédiat inférieur à ce que nous
connaissons tellement en france enfin
tout ça est précaire il ya une étude qui
est intéressant de la fondation jean
jaurès justement sur l'abstention qui
montre que c'est pas tellement une
désaffection vis-à-vis d'un désintérêt
vis-à-vis de la démocratie mais il ya le
sentiment qu'au fond la classe politique
ne répond plus aux attentes
qui sont deux qui sont sales d'aider des
citoyens vous pensez que c'est d'une
bonne explication dont d'avoir son
explication qui est un petit peu facile
et puis deuxièmement de souvent la
classe politique que l'on mérite je
pense que il ya un premier point
effectivement c'est que bien souvent la
classe politique vient le mot classe
politique me posait un problème puisque
classe politique j'espère que les
responsables maggiore colons sont issus
des citoyens tout cas c'est la réalité
pour les entreprises les élus locaux qui
me semble être beaucoup plus
représentatif des citoyens mais ils sont
coincés entre à la fois l'obligation qui
ne respectent pas d'expliquer le
pourquoi ils font les choses et le
pourquoi ils ne peuvent pas les faire ça
c'est la première première logique et
donc on a un sentiment de déception
quand on s'attend dans sa tombe
d'éléments qui ne sont pas faits mais on
était qu'ils ne peuvent pas être produit
ou modifiées donc il ya un manque à mon
sens de pédagogie des élus locaux qui
est désuet du nationaux qui n'explique
pas les choses premièrement et en même
temps quand il fond et c'est un peu ce
qu'on entend c'est les motifs de la le
niveau du débat est nulle et par
conséquent ça ne m'intéresse pas en même
temps les français adorent les débats
qui sont nuls parce que vous voyez ça
fait du buzz et ils ont beaucoup de mal
à se poser dans le temps pour analyser
la réalité des objectifs et des
motivations politiques si on explique
qu'on va distribuer le smic à 1500 euros
et qu'en même temps on n'a pas d'argent
pour le financement et qu'on en ait
manqué jeudi n'a jamais été atteint les
gens ont tendance à ne pas écouter la
con trat 1 espérer que la solution qui
aurait été est irréaliste et en plus je
rajouterais as a l'obligation tourna de
satisfaire à des moyens de communication
que nous ne sommes pas c'est un des
moyens de communication digitaux qui
aujourd'hui pouces avec un nombre de
mots très très limitée une pensée qui
sont sept complexes quand on pousse une
porte c'est qui est simple et qu'on peut
pas mettre en oeuvre évidemment génère
de la satisfaction puisqu'on ne voit
jamais la traduction dans les actes
politiques des grands projets simples
que l'on présente je reprenais le smic à
1500 euros mais c'était valable on va
stopper l'immigration ah oui comment on
sait pas on va on va dire non à l'europe
ah oui mais on oublie qu'on peut pas le
faire parce qu'on a des traités c'est
pas grave on va on respectera pas les
traiter mais en fait on peut pas le
faire à porter parce qu'on le dit vite
et parce que en même temps que j'ai un
match à us des beurres ensemble un peu
d'aidé des citoyens schizophrène
puisqu'on attend qu'on nous explique en
même temps veut pas entendre
d'explications ou vingt ans que des
solutions simples donc plus en parler
fort quand on sort fut non pas le simple
appât vos dix ans mais après je jouerai
trop long mais j'entends ça moi qui
tiens des bureaux doigt depuis des
années quand quelqu'un vient me dire
qu'il ya douze candidats et c'est la
même chose présidentielle je ne vote pas
pourquoi voter pas je te disais sont pas
représentés à bon vous avez même le
canard sur les affiches l'offre
politique on veut pas dire qu'elle est
pas là elle l aij et le parti
animalistes
si on peut pas dire aujourd'hui quand un
jour de campagne qu'on n'est pas
représenté l'offre elle existe lol
existe au deuxième tour évidemment
l'offre est restreint soit bien c'est
logique mais encore une fois j'ai ce
sentiment que l'on ne prend pas ces
temps pour expliquer mais qu'en même
temps non citoyens et moi le premier on
n'est pas apte à écouter les
explications et ça va de pair avec le
retrait la presse écrite c'est vrai
qu'il ya peut-être vers l'examen une
sorte de paradoxe parce que on voit un
mécontentement général ne généralisez et
en même temps que forte quand il ya des
élections les gens n'y vont pas alors il
y avait dans cette étude de la fondation
jean jaurès l'idée aussi peut-être que
les problèmes étaient tellement
complexes par exemple du réchauffement
climatique que ben y aurait pas de
réponses possibles par la politique il
ya aussi cette idée là enfin il ya
plusieurs idées qui explique qu'ils
peuvent expliquer cette abstention mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que ça brille
à ce paradoxe quand même des mécontents
et on va pas voter le paradoxe existe et
il ya le paradoxe de
l'ignorance rationnelle qui consiste à
dire d'emblée fin ccsa ronson qui a vécu
les choses c'est pour les lecteurs allez
voter mais pour quoi faire et m'avoir
représente peu dans un million deux ans
des millions d'électeurs est donc le
premier deux premiers points c'est ça
c'est l'électeur qui dans un premier
temps se dit mais à quoi bon ma voix ne
changera rien celui qui a links imagine
qu'on pourrait éventuellement faire
quelque chose ou qui peut croire aux
intentions ou promesses parce que pour
l'heure en est que dans les programmes
ne sont que des intentions on est dans
le cône hâtif dans l'intentionnalité
l'intention donc après on croit ou on ne
croit pas si on croit et que la tension
la promesse n'est pas mise en oeuvre une
fois élu il ya une perte de crédibilité
mais la déception est grande et donc et
un schéma qui peut c'est venu pour faire
très court il ya un schéma qui peut se
réaliser d'un point de vue théorique on
ice man qui avait envisagé jeudi
rejoindre parce que c'est vraiment
l'auteur le premier qui a parlé de exit
voice royalty alors exit je prends la
porte de sortie voice je revendique je
m'exprime et loyalty je reste fidèle à
mes intentions il prenait les on peut
prendre deux cas prendre une image par
exemple c'est je vais au restaurant la
soupe n'est pas bonne je fais appeler le
cuisinier et je lui fais part de mon
mécontentement la soul n'est pas bonne
je ne dis rien je pars et je ne
reviendrai plus je suis plus fidèles
c'est un milieu ne reverront plus la
soupe n'est pas bonne et je
exit vol soyaux tilloy youpi je reste
exit je pars et la revendication si je
fais savoir et l'autre possibilité c'est
je suis fidèle je ne fais pas bien le
cuisinier chenu derrien j'imagine que
aujourd'hui il était pas
ça veut dire demain je reste fidèle
fidélité non fidélité où je sors et là
on va voir la même chose
c'est qu'on peut avoir et je trouve
aussi un point supplémentaire c'est les
unions qui ont été faites alors la
stratégie de mélenchon et les
formidables et la marche est
formidablement d'ailleurs on pourrait se
poser la question si d'autres en avaient
fait autant aurait-il eu la même
aurait-il pu avoir la même là même la
même réussite et peut-être que la droite
aurait pu s'en inspirer mais pourquoi la
droite ne semble respire pas peut-être
parce que la droite a réfléchi un peu
plus ce que je veux dire l'union un site
dé tous les membres de l'union à faire
des compromis certains diraient des
compromissions à partir moi je suis dans
l'union je perds un peu ce qui faisait
ma colonne vertébrale et c'est en ça que
la droite a pour j'essaie de dire des
choses façon objective et non pas
partisane mais la droite a pris de
l'argument de dire on est sur le terrain
mais moi je dirais plus encore ils ont
pris l'argument de convictions
auxquelles ils ne voulaient pas déroger
là on a des partis qui font l'union qui
vont avoir des sièges qui font du buzz
mais après que vont-ils faire de ces
tueries c'est tout toute union quand
elle n'est pas quand elle est faite
d'éléments hétérogènes peut amener et
c'est mon dernier forme pour faire le le
finalement n'est pas d'un diplôme c'est
le
finalité à l'union peut amener des deux
côtés de du point de vue de l'offre et
de la demande c'est à dire que les
partenaires de l'union envoie de fidèles
le temps d'avoir les voix des électeurs
ils vont respecter lui non le ps qui des
quais dans les six pour être clair on
peut parler de la de la nuit ps ou de la
nuque je ne sais pas comment prononce
mais le ps qui est dans la nuque ce pour
l'instant il est dans les rup ce nom
mais l'idée c'est comme d'avoir un
groupe pour en sortir le plus vite
possible donc c'est vraiment manger ou
pas d'ailleurs où chacun va essayer de
sortir et pour les lecteurs c'est la
même chose les lecteurs mais piégé il va
simplement se dire est ce que je veux tu
es bon candidat ps n'est plus là on me
dit mon candidat ps c'est un hub se
maintenant bon candidat ps c'est à et
les filles on écolo candidat écolo est
un essai ce qui peut amener les
électeurs à avoir finalement laissé
tomber les élections vous êtes tellement
bout dimanche que certains sont dit bill
france en moins de 6 par rapport à
l'abstention il ya un autre paradoxe
aussi peut-être qu'on peut évoquer c'est
la volonté des français de participer un
peu plus dans la vie politique et
finalement de ne pas passer par une
démocratie représentative mais une
démocratie directe en parcours
participative et on le voit notamment
c'était l'une des revendications des
filets jaunes parmi de nombreuses
revendications c'était la volonté de
participer un peu plus dans la vie
politique et puis certains hommes
politiques aussi et femmes politiques
avancent l'idée que entre les cinq
années entre l'élection entre les
élections présidentielle et les
élections législatives certes il ya des
élections locales mais il ya aussi une
démocratie qu'il faudrait faire vivre
avec des rendez-vous participatif et là
j'aurais évoque ce que j'avais déjà
évoqué dans le paf mais tout ce qui est
budget participent participatif au
niveau local peut être un peu plus de
pouvoirs pour le cee aussi où on sait
qu'il pourrait y avoir des citoyens qui
pourraient s'ils viennent y assure dans
un conseil national de la refondation
dans ta balle et emmanuel macron qui
est notamment président ma république
prend en compte cette volonté de
participation à la vie démocratique de
la part de la population mais ya un
paradoxe quand même parce que on leur
donne la possibilité de s'exprimer dans
les urnes au français et il ne la
saisissent pas parce que peut-être
qu'ils veulent autre chose ça presque à
peut-être par cette démocratie
participative qui a été théorisée par je
ne sais plus quel politiste voici sais
pas
y
en a pas mal
politique j'ai parlé d'un chercheur
le gros politologue de gauche
un des leaders de la droite le nova de
revenir dans quelques instants la
qualité des citoyens sélectionnés pour
participer à ce genre d'organisme je la
mets quand même un petit peu en cause
parce que le
plaisir de connaître et j'ai pas le même
bagage flou c'est par esprit que le chef
a doctement politique plutôt géologie
alors ça ira mais est ce que je voulais
dire c'est quoi ce délire et qu'il riche
pour creuser mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que le rendu de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat riz par exemple
et la validité des membres moi mon
problème c'est une tendresse dans le
même voilà c'est sur les sujets et du
coup les rangs du qui ont sont faits me
semble très orienté quand même et
correspondent probablement pas l'intérêt
général de l'ensemble des citoyens et je
vois pas d'autres meilleur système que
l'expression du droit de vote et après
je prends un exemple très locales que
l'on connaît tous c'est l'obligation des
enquêtes publiques qui ont été très
renforcée avec la capacité de le faire
en digital pour réunir un maximum de
gens qui étaient là quand vous faites un
quartier dans lequel devait 6000
habitants vous devez réformes et que
vous êtes contrainte à cette enquête là
vous la fait communiquer dessus dans le
tas mais aussi par la télévision à la
radio par tracts dans les boîtes honnête
accélération à quelque 6000 habitants
vous avez 38 participation donc donc
c'est là où je reviens ce monde plein de
sites ainsi que aux réalités pardon la
majorité je pense qu elle reste
silencieuse ramène à brescia bardot ya
quand même quelque chose de da c'est
paradoxal aussi que nathan qui n'a pas
aidé énormément danon ça et qui s'est
pas lancé dans la campagne il nous parle
avant les législatives
gagnées autre match finalement
concurrentiel bon avec tous les tous les
défauts que vous avez signalé et si on
ne sait pas très bien comment il sera
organisé d'ailleurs mais enfin c'est
vrai qu'on le dit
on peut se dire mais à quoi ça sert
l'assemblée nationale si on va faire à
côté un conseil de celles de refondation
à ce moment là alors qu'il annonce pas à
pas grand chose d'autre mais il ya un
autre effet deux autres et fait qui
n'est jamais noté par les commentateurs
se gère 6 2 en ce qui concerne
l'abstention et qui sont des mécanismes
institutionnels
si vous prenez une élection quand vous
avez la majorité absolue
vous êtes normalement élu mais la règle
institutionnels veux que vous ayez votre
pourcentage correspond à 25% des
inscrits je vous donne un exemple
marine le pen obtient plus de 55% au
premier tour elle n'est pas élue au
premier tour pourquoi parce que c'est
55% ne correspondent douze ennemis pour
son nom là attention vous et moi j'y
reviens travaux non non c'est assez
compliqué non pouces demain quand on est
élu au premier tour avec une majorité
absolue donc quatre marines le père et
plus de 55% mais c'est ça quand ça pour
cent ne correspondent qu'à 23 pourtant
il dépoussière des inscrits du second
tour qui dit second tour dit avec des
possibilités de rejette du r'n que ce
qu'elle avait gagné majestueusement et
bien est remis en cause deuxième chose
et là on vient enfin au 12 et demi pour
cent et ça explique aussi à mon avis ça
peut expliquer aussi l'abstention
auparavant vous aviez la possibilité de
et vous avez toujours la possibilité de
triangulaires
mais pour une triangulaire
il faut pas simplement être en troisième
cadran gi badr angulaire également faut
pas simplement être en troisième ou
quatrième position c'est là qu'il faut
avoir avec votre pourcentage 12me deux
avantages 2
celui des inscrits ce qui bouge avec
l'abstention à 52 % il faut plus de 25%
des
navets pareil c'est du fait qu'il ya
plusieurs évidemment un nombre important
de candidats mais du coup qu'est ce qui
se passe et au niveau de l'abstention et
au niveau de la suite c'est qu'au lieu
d'avoir trois par exemple trois
candidats qui vont s'affronter au second
tour vous en avait que deux et vous
allez avoir dans de nombreuses
circonscriptions un ou une rn et donc
pour les lecteurs l'électeur devra
choisir entre rn ou nub sous les ruines
ensemble enfin les maquereaux nice tu es
donc ce problème cornélien
n'aurait pas eu lieu si il y avait une
triangulaire par exemple si vous aviez
eu l air ou udi vous aviez l'ups et et
rennes c'est pas compliqué je vote lr et
vous n'auriez pas eu tous ces débats qui
ont eu lieu ces jours ci et ce
cafouillage dans la majorité
présidentielle pour dire
tout sauf papa tout justement aucune
voix pour le rassemblement national mais
si on est républicain
ben on peut voter quand même pour
quelqu'un de la delà de la nuque sera
pourvu que les joies pas la position
d'ailleurs ce que je veux dire les
règles institutionnelles c'est vrai
qu'elle favorise le fait qu'il n'y ait
que des duels
et le clivage gauche droite qui est qui
était revenue en force il voilà donc un
système dans lequel
l'abstentionniste pèse plus que le vote
blanc il a plus de ratissages en queue
de poisson qui fait l'effort de venir
dire je veux blanc parce qu'aucun
candidat ne correspond c'est une
aberration voulais rajouter quelque
chose de mauvais temps les triangulaires
elle venait du pouvoir de nuisance du
sang frais du fn à l'époque et donc la
droite a beaucoup pâti aussi de
triangulaire où finalement la droite
était voyez ci voit splitté et la droite
ou vers des mots pas la perception à
cause des triangles 1,7 c'est pour ça
que là c'est pour ça que la loi était
modifiée d'ailleurs maintenant on
revient sur beaucoup de choses qui ont
été établies parce que il ya des
intentions derrière et qu'on peut
imaginer et puis le deuxième point il
voit beaucoup de duels effectivement
après que peut-on penser des des
consignes de vote parce que finalement
chacun y va de sa consigne de vote mais
il arrive un moment où on va finir par
bouclée parce que la stratégie qui a été
utilisée notamment par le parti de la
majorité présidentielle qui a consisté à
dire à l'élection présidentielle tous
sauf marine le pen un vote contre marine
le pen a instrumentalisé jean luc
mélenchon parce que finalement quand
même au deuxième tour il ya 41 % des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon qui ont
voté pour emmanuel macron dire même on
partage certaines valeurs avec les
majors finniste
en usent
utilise instrumentalise jean luc
mélenchon avant les législatives en dix
ans et en faisant ce ministère de la
planification écologique si je quittais
long terme voilà ils ont repris dans
l'andante voilà qu'ils sont mais c'est
un peu la triangulation d'alors des
triangulations elle est faite par tout
le monde et aujourd'hui donc
le diable c'est jean luc mélenchon donc
ça devient compliqué les consignes de
vote va être très compliqué
l'église a toujours l'adversaire
principe
peut-être que ça pour terminer ce sus à
ce poids en tout cas c'est des vecteurs
qui décide les lecteurs qui le juge de
paix c'est l'électeur qui décide et
parfois mais peut-être même que les
consignes de vote vont s'user à force
d'entendre des consignes soient les
lecteurs va dire je fais ce que je veux
et je vais être encore plus la cité a
voté contre ce qu'on me demande ou alors
il va rester à la maison et l'on
retrouve l'abstention trouble sur les
quand tu le dis quand souvent des
responsables politiques disent on n'est
pas propriétaire des votes iso réseau de
le faire même s'ils le font souvent par
une politique si on entend cette fois
juste un mot avant 2
juste tu as vu juste juste à bord juste
un mot sur eux mêmes sur la faune on en
a la pression comme ça que la démocratie
est un système qui existe de tout temps
et qui est qui existera toujours au fond
ça montre quand même sept abstentions
que c'est un régime qui fragile
c'est toujours été un régime fragile et
la démocratie est elle même évolutive si
on va leur part depuis la démocratie
grecque ou les bonbons les femmes
étaient exclus les esclaves également
salée qui travaillent le sait très bien
que les gens différents il faut que les
citoyens étaient censés ne pas seulement
celui qui ne travaille est qu'ils ne
travaillaient pas qu'on arrive jusqu'à
aujourd'hui où non seulement les femmes
votent depuis 1944 ce qu'il est très
récent mais où il y a un droit de vote
aussi pour les étrangers qui sont
européens aux municipales donc on voit
que le la démocratie sur le plan du vote
à 7 c'est véritablement étendu mais
simplement on revient à la question de
tout à l'heure il ya d'autres formes de
démocratie
la démocratie participative qui pourrait
être un lien qui ne devrait pas être en
concurrence avec les législatives parce
que aux législatives on parle de
l'intérêt général c'est à dire de toutes
les questions a simplement du climat ou
de je ne sais quelle autre de quelle
autre question mais il ya un troisième
troisième possibilité quand la
démocratie véritablement ne fonctionne
pas bien c'est la rue et c'est la rue
et on voit bien qu'il ya des crises
depuis les îles comme les gilet jaune et
aidera qui déplace le kid et place la
solution politique vers la rue plutôt
que vers les assemblées ou vers la
délibération comment ça c'est vrai que
diable importations y compris dedans
dans l'est les analyses de dire mais
finalement un régime autoritaire alors
ne parlons pas de poutine mais un régime
autoritaire au moins ces tranchées on
les questions c'est que c'est comme ça
il sait pas et c'est pas autrement et il
ya une tentation m'appelait tous deux de
deux régimes il ya des sonneries et est
très inquiétant là-dessus inquiets
qu'ils montraient qu'il y avait une
impétueuse d'une grande banque de france
et pour un régime autoritaire et si on
prend les jeunes dans les sourdins je
vois que l'attachement à la démocratie
il devient minoritaire donc c'est ça
pose des problèmes peut-être un beau
parcours sur les amoureux sur les
yvelines pour dire que le département
des yvelines finalement elle est
meilleure et élèves que la moyenne
nationale
à une abstention pardon qui est en
dessous des 50%
faut dire quand même que les yvelines
c'est comme au niveau national je pense
c'est que en fonction de la catégorie
sociale ou lou de laage eh bien on est
plus ou moins abstentionnistes je vais
prendre un exemple avec les quartiers
populaires 70% d'abstention aux mureaux
plus de 60% les jeunes
voilà exactement puis plus on est plus
on est une catégorie sociale défavorisée
comment se déplacent aux yeux oui dans
les quartiers
je crois pas les quartiers il ya une
absorption très forte et je lui disais
70% aux mureaux plus de 60% à trappes ou
encore à la verrière et puis on verra
plus tard dans l'émission et que ça sera
décisif notamment dans la 11e
circonscription et la 8e circonscription
seulement eh ben on va pardon pardon
peut aussi se poser la question de
comment les faire en sorte que les
jeunes en viennent voter et même si j'ai
personnellement je suis très attaché aux
symboles républicains pour beaucoup de
raisons je pense aussi qu'on se doit de
faire probablement évoluer techniquement
le mode de scrutin et qu'à l'époque on
paye ses impôts on a été un peu avec son
téléphone portable j'avoue que même si
ça me fait parfois mal parce que j'aime
bien le bureau de vote et leurs écuelles
et le train chéri tu es je pense que
souvent des jeunes viennent voter il
faut aussi aller vers des méthodes
modernes de votre à distance du paddy
par correspondance j'ai dit à distance
de manière informatique et qu'on vienne
pas me sentir le sempiternel oui mais la
sécurité on est en capacité aujourd'hui
d'avoir des méthodes très sécuritaire
pour garantir le vote et je suis certain
que si on le faisait on serait
certainement bien au delà de ça on peut
voter pendant deux jours enfin je vais
lui donner cet exemple quand je vois
qu'on revoie très ouverts jusqu'à 20h
alors que ça pourrait essayer plein pays
qui vit qui votent dans semaine pourquoi
il s'est dit d'euros soit ouvert à 20
heures entre 18h et 20h et actions
personnes sur l'été en digital tout doit
voter la veille et puis les résultats
seraient donnés en trois minutes non
mais j'ai et pardon je voulais le film
je pense que alors on voit que la façon
voté la façon dont les gens vivent à
évoluer nous sommes restés sur un vote
un peu archaïque
ces années
présente elle s'est peut-être des
derniers scrutins au
vote majoritaire
c'était le dernier scrutin uninominal à
deux tours pour législatives c'est qu'on
nous annonce la proportionnelle des
positions qui étaient annoncés aussi
c'est le maître l'élection
présidentielle le même jour que
l'élection du syndic chez lui
en tout cas ça demandera ddd des
réformes et un style du modèle est sûre
doute politique ils ont bu pour essayer
d'aider ou du courage on va parler des
résultats évidemment parce que c'est
important et cette deuxième date de
l'émission
[Musique]
vous le disiez il y aura beaucoup de
duels
deuxième tour ou faux gardons gros il ya
en effet un bon comportement de la
gauche de la nuque même si
même si quand on regarde si on regarde
par rapport à 2010 est si on ajoute les
voix du pc du ps de l'efi et des écolos
il faisait plus en 2010 est que comme
qu'aujourd'hui parce que au fond dit oui
mais voilà si beau comportement c'est
vrai enfin ils sont à 25 26 % c'est pas
c'est quand même pas énorme non mais les
matrones is not least 6 à 7 par rapport
à 17 voire six ou sept fois par rapport
à 2010 est oui cette question de d'avoir
un bloc et avec la nuque ce c'est très
très important à tel point que
c'est cette idée que sera comptabilisé
au résultat les parures y est pas la
nuque c'est évidemment cela revenus à la
situation de
2010 est donc là vous voyez il ya aussi
encore un élément un élément est
institutionnel
mais le fait qu'il y ait ce bloc a créé
une dynamique sans compter que mélenchon
et être pratiquement le seul à faire
véritablement campagne marine le pen
était fatigué on la comprend enfin
c'était peut-être pas le moment d'aller
se reposer
les maquereaux nist sont restées
silencieuses disant pas de vagues pas de
vagues toute façon ça va nous arriver ça
va nous tomber du ciel bon c'est quelque
part c'est comme ça qu'est une forme
d'arrogance ac et donc
on se trouve maintenant avec je crois
373 gibbs au second tour donc si la
plupart des duels sont nulles ce voile
ailleurs souvent d'autres espèces et
plus et dont 60 minutes ce
rassemblement national oui il y avait
rassemblé nationale alors sur le oui non
sur sur la gauche quand même donc oui
oui il ya il ya quelque chose qui s'est
passé puisqu'ils sont premiers ou
deuxièmes sont ses façades et le
problème des terres natales 102e mais
mélenchon dit comment truquer les
chiffres
mais il ya alors le problème où ça
posséder aussi le problème de la réserve
de voix parce que c'était des élections
à deux tours
non attendez simplement effectivement on
prend des cartes des lapins ou les maris
ensemble à plusieurs quartiers de lapin
pour rejoindre la majorité donc du grill
et plus de réserves de voix de fête
puisque la réserve de voix à les
conglomérats alors que c'est
effectivement ai vu une séparation on
aurait peine à des circonscriptions dans
lequel effectivement deuxième tour on
pourrait ramener vers soi est d'ailleurs
avoir une petite de communication de
programme aussi de consensus parce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure et très juste
pour un millier à la fois vague il est
complexe et je vois mal certains partis
candidats ex socialiste pouvoir adhérer
à l'ensemble des idées qui sont mêmes
sabots de la compromission quand même
des choses
incroyables donc simplement impossible
quand vous êtes dans une logique de
second tour dans un modèle traditionnel
vous riez pas juste que l'addition des
noms il ya l'addition des programmes le
compromis entre guillemets après
l'allemande qui se met en place avec une
vraie une vraie programmatique en lequel
des électeurs éventuels qui l'ont
d'ailleurs pas voté pour vous pour les
tours peuvent vous rejoindre là c'est
assez compliqué parce que effectivement
du ps reste dans un un algorithme de
pour programmatique le même qu'il était
au premier tour il n'a pas deux parties
petit ou secondaire qui peut le
rejoindre et il n'y a pas de programme
différenciant qui est issue la logique
de la stratégie d alliance du premier
tour donc effectivement c'est pas de
réserve de voix passe capable non plus
de réserves de programmes et localement
on le voit bien dire qu'on peut
quasiment quasiment faire les résultats
du deuxième tour avec un tableau excel
ce qui d'habitude n'est pas le cas vous
ne le ferez total à
ses collègues à côté de moi pour le
faire mais c'est vrai que ça m'a rappelé
un peu le alors c'est une autre élection
qui est très différente mais mitterrand
74 éviter en 81 74 idée candidat unique
de la gauche il fait 46 % au premier
tour mais il n'arrive pas aux 50% au
deuxième tour
c'est à 49
avec un score énorme au premier tour et
mais il ne veut pas de réserve pas
tellement de réserves puisqu'il était
candidat unique de la gauche et en 81 il
fait beaucoup moins au premier tour mais
il est élu assez largement au deuxième
parce qu'il y avait il y avait en effet
d'aider des renforts possibles entre les
deux tout c'est vrai que ça me pose un
problème c'est celui de m le réseau doit
raisonner en termes de réserves de voix
il faut aussi raisonner en termes de
celui qu'on ne veut pas je n'en ai dit
aussi donc en ce qui concerne la gauche
si vous trouvez en face graduelle qui
nous lie à un rassemblement national on
va peut-être quand même voter
le candidat c'est celui celui qui
verseraient puis un deuxième élément sur
les réserves de voix donc ça joue aussi
pour le pour le rassemblement national
quand il ya un duel avec
les maquereaux nist on veut vraiment pas
de macron on vote à gauche dont on a
encore des surprises qui peuvent faire
le mieux possible vous avez raison parce
que quand on les sodas schmutt quand on
leur demande aux français est ce que
vous voulez donner une majorité
législative à vue nouvelle macro il
réponde non un assez fort pourcentage a
donc dont il va y avoir il y aura
probablement dans ce deuxième tour un
certain nombre d'électeurs qui voudront
voté contre la majorité absolue au
maquereau distiller l'idée d'un
rééquilibrage leader
on n'est pas d'accord avec aucun des
deux duels mais on va voter celui qui
est contre macro parce qu'il faut
rééquilibrer avoir redonné au parlement
un certain rôle de contre-pouvoir
schizophrène ça peut aussi c'est la
balance des pouvoirs l'américaine
président effectivement on va avoir des
institutions avec des couleurs
indépendante fin des couleurs opposées
mais là le problème c'est que finalement
quand on
quand on s'interroge sur ce qui va se
passer sur les réserves de voix on peut
avoir une idée zollitsch en plein
passage à vide je n'ai pas assez dormi
mais je les dires plusieurs ce vote
utile c'est ça que je cherchais la
question du vote utile le vote utile
c'est un argument qui marche qui
essayent de finalement qui a été
utilisée je dirais usées aujourd'hui et
je me pose la question de savoir parce
que j'essaie de mettre du côté des
lecteurs est-ce qu'il a encore envie de
voter utile quand il s'aperçoit que
finalement son vote utile est dévoyée
que le jeu revient à cette idée de
programme on lui dit bon bah voilà c'est
tout sauf tout sauf s'était même aussi
bien du tout sauf sarkozy que du tout
sauf le ban fallu tout sauf mélenchon
donc là les lecteurs ils voient pas plus
loin que le bout de son nez désolé mais
l'électeur exprime dans ce qu'on appelle
une forme de myopie donc les lecteurs et
court termiste il voit à court terme il
se dit oui effectivement et puis on voit
déjà je crois qu'il ya un pourcentage
pratiquement au dessus de la moyenne qui
commence à dire on est insatisfait de
macron version 2 2 au liban alors qu'il
n'a rien fait n'est pas commencée l'a
juste fait quelques quelques promesses
et donc les lecteurs qui y qui est dans
cette logique se dit bah oui allons-y
votons utile on va essayer de tout sauf
mais le problème c'est que ensuite
passer l'élection est ce que les
promesses seront tenues est ce qu'il ya
une crédibilité là on a un gros problème
voilà tout ce sont des gens n'est pas un
programme mais emmanuel macron nous
montre aujourd'hui que finalement il a
été élu certes bien est lui réélu certes
ccc rien à dire contre ça mais il n'a
pas de soutien politique je m'explique
soutien politique les la crédibilié
polluent la popularité des manuels
macron est en déficit il y a plus de
mécontents que de satisfaits il est à
41% de satisfaits donc l'alien déficit
est ce qu'on interprète canton quand on
veut regarder un peu les choses je
dirais dans un angle politique ou
économique ça signifie que le soutien
politique n'est pas là ça signifie qu'il
n'y a pas d'état de grâce et là c'est
terrible parce que c'est en état de
grâce que le président peut normalement
assez confortablement mettre en place
des réformes les plus compliqué la
réforme des retraites pourquoi on nous
dit qu'elle sera alors j'ai bien si j'ai
bien compris ce sera fini à l'été 2000
23 mai entre les deux je ne vois pas ce
qui se passe c'est à dire qu'on va voir
le résultat on nous l'a mis beaucoup de
concertation mon ami
mais elles sont reportés parce qu'on
sent que ça allait bien et sans soutien
politique ne pas parce vous pouvez pas
aller aux législatives en disant on va
faire la réforme de retraite à 65 ans
alors qu'il y en a un autre qui vous dit
bonne on a 60 ans ça va très vite c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué
si vraiment fait réforme des retraites à
65 ans si on dit ah les lecteurs on l'a
fait ils votent pour il ne sera pas
étonné n'ira pas dans la rue quand on
lui annonce trailer est fondamental
promet des lendemains compliqués
peut-être peut-être pas les lecteurs va
pas comprendre et là c'est le troisième
tour social garanti enfin moi c'était
une des craintes que j'ai sont ceux sur
cet aspect
nombreux sont ceux qui n'ont pas dû
vivre les périodes de cohabitation
pourrait penser qu'il n'est pas positif
d'envoyer de majorité à présent qui a
été élu tout de suite après les
élections parce que cohabitation vie la
vraie souvenons nous de ce que ça donne
ça donne rien au fait il ne se passe
rien su se bâtir vient de mesures est
parce qu il y avait eu une embellie
économique les vaillants
plus cher
elle a duré cinq ans la cohabitation
aussi donc des centaines aux éditions
logo mais tellement mais ludiquement je
préfère pourtant je suis ici en tant que
pape par lully donc je devrais dire
qu'il faut pas le faire mais moi je
préfère quand même un système dans
lequel la démocratie alors pas la
démocratie là pour le coup la démocratie
s'est exprimée et n'est vraiment les
réformes se met en place parce que le
système bloqué et d'ailleurs il est
prévu pour ne pas être bloqués quand il
était président ça fonctionne et par
contre on n'est pas d'accord on
sanctionne le coup d'après et où on
fonctionne aux élections terminées ce
qui va ce sera très intéressant de voir
les prochaines extraite à mes biens ou
franchement bien fort peut-être vous
prenez les leurs nous vient des
prévisions suffisamment l'avancé jérôme
les barreaux on a l'impression d'être
des élections de mi mandat oui c'est
vrai que le calendrier là y compris un
mois des élections de mi mandat mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que ça nous
rappelle que la réélection du président
ce n'est pas la même chose qu'une
élection il ya quand même il ya quand
même une différence
aussi cnse notion de personnalisation du
candidat qui l'emportent par rapport au
programme s'il revient sur le sujet tout
à l'heure sur le côté marketing
raccourcissement des messages il faut
que le ou la candidate soit belle
qu'elle parle bien qu'elle accroche les
jeunes etc
le contenu je suis certain que si on
devrait peut-être davos est le sondage
de quel est le contenu des programmes
des uns et des autres à mon avis on
aurait des surprises oui parodie alors
le montant du smic c'est pourquoi alors
1500 milles avec lui l'année 2000 serco
fait je pense que j'en mets ne
connaissent pas improbable il ne les lis
pas enfin ils connaissent le nom des
partis parce qu'avec toutes ces études
et marketing donc là on s'est dit dans
mon parcours de l'huile est jolie elle
elle parle bien il est beau il s'exprime
bien il était sur twitter il était en
sueur switch je veux pas donner de cas
mais je connais personnellement ma
famille j'en ai dit je veux tu n'es pas
bon pour quoi ils parlent aux jeunes
mais commencer par le jeune femme me
ogel d'affilée pourquoi il parle aux
jeunes sur tweets parce que sur switcher
met d'accord et le conduise a dit quoi
ces deux heures de retard mais il a
parlé aux jeunes c'est un peu ceci dit
quand tu es d'alema comprend marie
cariou c'est la même logique il espère
que tu là et on va chercher l'accord des
électeurs on l'a toujours fait c'est
sylvie durand va chercher les électeurs
on parle plus de foot qu'on parle plus
de fonds comme quoi le vote n'est pas
rationnel et l'irrationnel j'aimerais
tellement d'accord en fait la différence
alors entre le gars et la paix que je
pense qu'il est dans l'irrationalité il
est pas dans le fondement il est là
dedans et quand on parlait de leurs deux
49 51 d'époque parce qu'on est tous
paniqué audio la majorité d'aujourd'hui
sont fragiles côtes où l'ailier 49 51
personnes déjà été très vite pourtant
vous avez même fragilité mais on était
dans les rationnels et d'ailleurs
mitterrand c'est aussi par le jeune à
l'époque on n'était pas jamais il parler
aux jeunes s'ils génèrent donc je vais
accomplissement va les radios libres
joseph je suis dessus de tout enfin les
radios les mais c'était un super on
parle aux jeunes le programme économique
qui a des moyens quand même il
n'existait pas les gens voyaient pas
donc on vote pour du marketing comme
jamais
alors patrice vous croyez vous vraiment
que les gens des portes était pour
l'initialisation optionnelles ou les
nationalisations savoir pourquoi
il y avait aussi y avait aussi une part
de vote contre giscard 80 guerrière
justement politiques mesquines élection
qui est intéressant temps législatif et
78 premier tour la gauche s'est tassée
en bonne position tout le monde pense
qu'il va peut-être y avoir une
cohabitation et il ya un retour de la
droite entre les deux taux ça peut
arriver ça kéké des changements tout
autant tout est arrivé et d'autant qu'il
n'y a pas simplement la part du candidat
mais comme on joue davantage sur le
sentiment finalement c'est ça que sur la
raison il ya aussi l'importance du récit
mêlant chant il fait rêver la retraite à
60 ans 1500 euros il fait rêver et en
face il
problème aujourd'hui ce qu'ils ont envie
dans le temps il lutte armée
récit ce qu'on appelle un storytelling
et par conséquent on et entraîner là
dedans et au moins on sort du marasme de
la grisaille et des de la vérité
finalement c'est vrai qu'en mx2 quand
elisabeth bornes dit le le choix de sa
nomination je voudrais dire aux petites
filles aller au bout de vos rêves je
suis pas sûr que le rêve des petites
filles c'est de mettre la retraite à 65
ans
même si notre ministre est quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire est ce que vous pensez
qu'elle nous fait rêver en fait c'est
cette pro ben oui nicolas
démocratie participative parce que le
politiste m'est revenu en tête c'est
jürgen habermas
l'éditeur allemand qui a favorisé
théorisait la démocratie participative
sociale a aussi à vous pouvez leur prix
là dessus et il ya influencée notamment
ségolène royal je ferme la parenthèse
juste pour répondre à laurent et donc il
y avait donc et dont elle était
directrice de cabinet de ségolène j'ai
très juste pour répondre alors ça a
toujours existé finalement c'est juste
qu'aujourd'hui le média qui change avant
il y avait d'autres télévisions
l'apparition la télévision que le
général de gaulle à utiliser on suit
aujourd'hui c'est juste que c'est parce
que c'est digitalisées du coup ben on
touche plus les jeunes avec le digital
ya plus de masse disons que c'est pour
ça que peut-être que ça choque entre
guillemets aujourd'hui non c'était sympa
que ça choque c'est parce que je voulais
dire c'est même chose à te dire que ça
démultiplie la capacité de la parole
immédiate rapide dans la poche de chacun
d'entre nous dans la page pardon de ce
que je veux dire je vais aux toilettes
je regarde regarde quoi je devenais un
tweet j'ai même plus combien de
caractère de 144 j'en sais rien en trois
secondes n'importe où n'importe quand et
du coup le temps de la réflexion lui il
a disparu alors qu'avant j'étais un
tribun je m'adresse à une foule je vous
ai fait une réunion publique aujourd'hui
en campagne électorale qui vient la
réunion publique 2-3 vos opposants pour
vous écouter et mettre le bazar et vos
adhérents voire même les éléments vous
allez chercher à côté vous d'y remplir
ça en place un remplaçant les autres ils
sont où ils sont chez eux ils sont mais
ce qui est très bien sauf que il n'y a
pas le temps de la réflexion il ya pas
tant d kouthia pas le temps de la
comparaison et je compte par sedan sont
44 mo venez comme vous êtes face et du
marketing c'est de la pub c'est pas
choquant mais ya pas de fonds j'en
reviens à mon sujet il n'y a pas de
fonds et d'ailleurs où est la différence
aujourd'hui réellement entre allez
pardon entre les rues des imac rond on
va me dire des amis bientôt comment tu
dis ça et tout bien sûr qu'à des
différences mais c'est dans des tailles
des programmes et comme personne ne va
lire le détail des programmes on juge
sur l'apparence les phrases courtes les
petites les petites interventions dans
les stratégies personnelles d'où il
vient et ce qu'il a battu son chien ce
qu'il a tapé son chat s qui joue au golf
world food fin voilà le marketing qui a
toujours existé mais qui a pris tout le
lead les tout le lead marketing
politicien c'est alors que je voudrais
qu'on fasse comme
les décors comme un feuilleton
les candidats tout dépend de leur
implantation locale et c'est là que les
élèves on en parlera peut-être enfants
voilà sont finalement
en bonne en pologne des cultures
il ya quand même quelque chose qui colle
assez assez assez paradoxal les délires
le rn fait un peu plus de dix neuf et
demi pour cent des voix aux législatives
ils vont avoir on dit entre 30 et 40
députés
lr 11% ils vont avoir probablement plus
de députés que le rnc c'est la preuve de
ce que vous dites c'est à dire qu'ils
ont des candidats ils ont des gens qui
sont implantées dans les territoires
finalement la droite la droite
républicaine
c'est pas aussi catastrophique
coprésidents si l'on peut dire ça comme
ça mais vous regardez c'est là aussi
qu'il ya un paradoxe si vous regardez
autant nuxe bien petit faut voir à
l'intérieur il repartit que
levac rhône east non pas
d'interprétation lors hors ce type
d'élection est à la fois national et
régional local
en conclusion de la gauche donc nuxe va
profiter de l'implantation locale par
exemple
notamment notamment des socialistes et
puis un versement ait l'air maintenant
nam nam la pub leader bon sur le plan
national c'est un peu la bérézina mais
ils sont présents sur lesquels il doit
toujours présent donc ya pas simplement
là par an si elle a pris la parole la
présence d'un président dont les limites
de la logique nationale l'a emporté sur
la logique on va le voir justement dans
un instant
[Musique]
savais que j'avais juste une question
quand même imposé c'est dire que s'il
n'y a pas de majorité absolue on va
avoir un parti charnière qui sait
peut-être alerte et enfin il va y avoir
des négociations est ce que au fond
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour la
démocratie
même si laurent nous dit moi je
préférerais une chose claire mai
demande toi existera des compromis au
premier rang pour mission mais voilà les
libéraux car d'ailleurs un essai était
l'amant d'annaud midavaine dose de
proportionnelle
cette institution
appartient la question de la démocratie
le débat au moins va être engagée j'ai
effectivement on aura des compromis et
si on avait la proportionnelle on serait
on irait forcément versa automatiquement
mais alors paraît-il que c'est pas dans
la culture française
mais on voit mal et puis les l'air s'en
défendent dans l'immédiat qui est un
accord entre les bacs ronis tu es l air
est en revanche et une sont pas contre
les républicains pourront ils sont ils
disent nous on est pour l'intérêt
général etc pourront donner une majorité
sur tel ou tel projet l'opposition
constructive c'est à peine le position
si c'est un gouvernement du centre
plutôt qu'un gouvernement et les filles
bien comprendre c'est oui il met en son
premier ministre tu corriges qu'on peut
ce qu'on peut dire quand même une fois
pour toutes là parce que ça me paraît
assez clair
l'idée de mélenchon premier ministre
elle est enterrée c'était du marketing
on
peut dire ça
non ça va mieux en le disant ouais en
plus nommé premier ministre quelqu'un
qui lui même n'était pas de bruit on dit
dans cette rencontre mais
l'hypothèse d'une victoire du ps elle
n'existe plus on est bien d'accord même
si ils ont fait un bon score au premier
tour on passe aux yvelines fait un gros
plan sur les yvelines alors
[Musique]
on va peut-être regarder d'ailleurs les
tableaux des résultats des régionales
dans chaque circonscription
donc ça c'est la première
circonscription on voit que charles
rodwell arrive en tête avec 33% des
suffrages de la première circonscription
c'est versailles montigny et guyancourt
donc voilà on voit que la majorité
présidentielle arrive largement devant
le candidat de l'ani baisse sébastien
ramage
concernant la deuxième circonscription
et bien c'est jean-noël barrot ensemble
étiqueté modem qui arrive en tête 2e
circonscription composée de plusieurs
communes comme les loges en josas
ya versailles a joué en josas et puis le
nord de la vallée de chevreuse avec
cerner la ville ou encore saint rémy les
chevreuse
la troisième circonscription c'est
béatrice piron qui est en tête largement
aussi en tête avec près de 40% des voix
devant louise brody de la nuque baisse
alors qu'il a fait une balle candidats
puisque à l'origine
à fait monsieur blanc cassé jean michel
lambert qui était pressenti pour être
candidat dans la troisième
circonscription par circonscription
plusieurs communes comme les
clayes-sous-bois l'etang-la-ville donc
là aussi pareil à un territoire où est
la catégorie populaire et sont les
équations
cernant la 4e circonscription même
phénomène là on dépasse les 40% avec
marie le bec candidat de la majorité
présidentielle face à céline bourdon de
la nuque est ce pareil territoire aisé
au tour est bien de maisons laffitte par
exemple commune de la 4e circonscription
5e circonscription
eh bien c'est la ministre d outre mer il
ya elle brode tibet devant qui doit se
doit de l'emporter si elle veut
rester ville il y aurait il servait son
poste au ministère d outre-mer elle
devance la candidate sophie était venue
de la nuque baisse et c'était là la côte
est là ces gros ception où elle est
présentée par alexandra du blanche qui
est vice président du conseil régional
qui est bien implanté conseil municipal
d'auch à tout va tout maire de
sartrouville et qui n'est pas qualifié
pour le 2ème qui n'est pas qualifié pour
le tour par là pour faire de l air alors
concernant la 6e circonscription
circonscription de saint germain en laye
bc natalia pussy rêve député sortant qui
va de la majorité présidentielle qui est
largement devant mélinda sujet pour la
nuque baisse jusque là on a on a des 2e
tour a priori pose aucun problème belle
et les tous les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle sont en position en
ballottage favorable pour le savoir il
ya d'autres circonscriptions alors c'est
via une ligne très important localement
comme ça regardez alors c'est très
positif
[Musique]
en plus de cette circonscription nadia
et ancien ministre délégué à la ville
arrive est aussi
arrivé de peu en tête 29 points 55% avec
la candidate de la nuit baisse qui est
au coude à coude avec 27% des voix
michel christophoul concernant la 8e
circonscription là il y aura plus
d'enjeu puisque c'est la nuque mais ce
qui arrive en tête avec benjamin lucas
avec 33% des voix ce qui représente 3000
voix d'écart avec la candidate de l'art
présent de la majorité présidentielle
est vive hervieu alors c'est mon c'est
alors c'est montrent la jolie c'est la
circonscription de mantes-la-jolie et du
nord du département alors si on doit
faire un point sur cette circonscription
il faut dire un certain michel vial et
qui arrive en quatrième position
derrière cyril note du rassemblement
national cyril note qui est ans l'ancien
maire de mantes la ville donc on aime le
rassemblement national qui arrive en
troisième position devant le candidat
traduit leur vie de deuxième tour ni
sera sûrement ravis du deuxième tour on
le verra après je reviendrai dans
l'analyse un peu plus précises notamment
de la 8e circonscription et puis de la
11ème qu'on va voir juste après
concernant la 9e circonscription
eh bien on retrouve le candidat de la
majorité présidentielle bruno myle yen
qui arrive en tête devant laurent maurin
et donc c'est la première fois dans le
département des yvelines qu'on retrouve
un candidat du rassemblement national au
second tour d'une élection législative
lauro morin qui a été maire adjoint de
mantes la ville qui représentera le
rassemblement national et on ça confirme
que le résultat des élections
présidentielles qu'on avait analysé
c'est à dire que les communes rurales du
nord du département à la frontière avec
l'eure et loir et l'heure est bien vote
pour le rassemblement national donc
l'extrême droite s'installe clairement
dans le nord du département mais il ya
des villes
morin est en tête je peux vous en donner
quelques unes gd bruno mediène a tweeté
que en cas de sylvère un duel entre 2 et
rennes et la nuque mais si votre et du
ps
je sais pas si ça c'était une conviction
et puis et puis aussi les aider face à
court d'idées rennes enfin quelques
résultats par exemple bonnière freneuse
et bien scellé même résultat qu'à la
présidentielle c'est le rassemblement
national arrive en tête dans ses jardins
social actuellement c'est le cas aussi
de flins sur seine voilà on a en parlé
puisque c'est là où est située l'usiné
renault est bien flins sur seine a voté
à me placer laurent morin en tête
concernant maintenant la 10e
circonscription on descend dans le sud
des yvelines et dans la le territoire
durant bolida et bien c'est la députée
sortante aurore bergé qui arrive
largement il ne devrait pas y avoir de
surprise on verra au second tour face au
candidat de l'ani baisse cédric briolet
la 11e circonscription cette commune
autour de trappes de la verrière
d'elancourt là aussi d'élus teaser
trailer saint cyr de fontenay-le-fleury
de tête aux médecins crédible mais ni
israël ni et bien c'est dégueulasse
aille à l air qui étaient deux députés
sortants député sortant de vérifier
n'est pas qualifié et c'est william
martin et de la nuque est ce qui arrive
en tête devant la candidate aurait ni
pia senza de la majorité présidentielle
pareil on reviendra dans les détails
mais s'il ya 2000 voix d'écart entre les
deux candidats donc là aussi le second
tour risque d'être serré il y à match
com me dire dans l'émission pour revenir
sur les résultats des élections
législatives et enfin la 12e
circonscription c'est le territoire
entre plaisir et poissy et bien c'est
merveilleux
qui arrive en tête président et
représentant la majorité présidentielle
devant et devine le grise de la nuque
baisse ce qui suppose un changement si
la loi le maire à la mairie de poissy ce
qui est loin d'être anecdotique ouais
mais bon oui parce qu'on peut y ait pas
de cumul des mandats possibles entre
maires et députés on voit en gros si si
si on voit les choses en grand il ya
deux circonscriptions ou qui sont plutôt
pain incertaine même si si le tableau
excel vous me donner des résultats ça
m'arrange mais cette formation financée
elle me tienne la vie d'hier une onzième
alors la situation la 11e
circonscription donc il y a deux mille
voix d'écart entre les deux candidats au
premier tour il ya une réserve de voix
pour la majorité présidentielle
notamment chez les républicains quand on
rentre dans les détails que l'irena
sayyaf est à peu près de 17% je crois
que c'est ça
je crois qu'il si je sais plus le nombre
de 6000 voix 6000 voix pour aurignac rue
des piats senza pardon 18
et quand on rentre dans les détails dont
4 ap williams martinez dépasse les 50% à
la verrière idée pas il est au dessus
des 40 % mais par contre quand on
regarde la participation dans ces deux
villes eh bien il ya près de 60%
d'abstention à la verrière et 63 %
d'abstention à trappes et donc la
réserve de voix pour la nuque et sceller
la sls dans l'abstention en fait
question verde que war belle le c'est
vrai qu'on voit que les les parties
essaient de mobiliser les électeurs vous
pensez qu'il peut y avoir une
mobilisation plus forte au deuxième tour
cela s'est passé
en général il ya eu une abstention plus
forte second tour mais il ya plus de
vitalité lors de la campagne
voilà mais après tout défensif tout
dépend de ce qui va mobiliser les
lecteurs parce que on d'immobilisation
quand on annonce que votre camp et
vainqueur ça peut faire un effet de
bonnes vagues en effet d'entraînement
qui va faire on va confirmer sa victoire
quand on annonce que votre candidat est
perdant soit vous êtes complètement
déçus sont au contraire il savoure
grigor et ça vous incite à aller donc
savoureux mobilise donc là on ne sait
pas après le problème c'est qu'on est
avec un choix restreint donc il ya des
duels qui vont peut-être donner envie
d'exprimer une colère à certains et à
d'autres qui ont dit à l'écouté des
bruits et vous entre vous c'est nini et
on va laisser on va laisser faire donc
ça peut donc c'est assez compliqué c'est
ce qui est difficile à prévoir
l'abstention c'est nous et on peut
modéliser c'est ce qu'on ne me dise pas
vraiment
très compliqué
8e circonscription on a manqué la jolie
et bien donc le candidat du ps jean-luc
a obtenu 33 % des voix c'est 3000 voix
d'écart par rapport à edvige hervieux et
à mantes-la-jolie benjamins lucas est
largement devant la candidate ensemble
avec plus de 40% des voix 63% des bois
ne sont pas déplacés donc là aussi on
voit que il ya un une réserve de voix
chez les abstentionnistes
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que il
va pas y avoir énormément de voix pour
le rassemblement national et pour les
républicains 6700 électeurs du
rassemblement national et 2300 électeurs
des républicains c'est la réserve de
voix pour la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle donc la clé pour la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale ce sera la participation dans
sérieuses au piano script sion où aller
chercher comme vous l'avez dit est ce
que le mécontentement par rapport à la
politique d' emmanuel macron 20
mobiliser les votes autrement les
électeurs du rassemblement national des
républicains vers las nubes et bien en
tout cas c'est ce que souhaite aller
chercher les deux candidats de ces deux
circonscriptions qu'on va écouter
la jeunesse les quartiers populaires est
en fait toutes celles et tous ceux qui
veulent tourner la page d' emmanuel
macron se sont mobilisés et massivement
donc bonne nouvelle pour le premier tour
mais soyons très clairs pour le second
tour il faut passer un cap
supplémentaire tous ceux qui se
sentaient pas encore concernés par cette
élection maintenant qu'ils vont pouvoir
choisir entre emmanuel macron ou la
nouvelle union populaire maintenant il
faut qu'ils se déplacent il faut qu'ils
fassent le choix c'est évidemment les
abstentionnistes mais je le dis aussi à
celles et ceux qui ont fait d'autres
choix moi je ferai en sorte de
travailler avec tout le monde y compris
avec ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
moi à la question c'est est ce qu'on a
besoin d'un député aux ordres de macron
bresse qu'on a besoin d'un député libre
et qu'il descend ce territoire et cette
circonscription est ce que veulent ses
habitants pour le pouvoir d'achat les
services publics c'est ça le sujet la
question c'est aussi un référendum sur
la retraite à 65 ans donc on aura des
surprises moi je vous le dis je pense
qu'elles les électrices et les électeurs
que que vous classé à droite mais qui
refusent la politique d' emmanuel macron
un autre confusion parce que
malheureusement quittés à mal les
yvelines a pourrait conclure
une évolution qui est un homme
remarquable c'était finalement la droite
les républicains qui pendant longtemps
enfin les gaullistes oui
c'était la première force politique
centre-droit
disons qu'en
2017 il avait onze c'était de la le
flambeau est passé au maquereau nist qui
sur douze circonscriptions avaient même
onze je voulais juste le huitième avec
michel vialay qui était resté en l'air
et eo2 est la vôtre il est redevenu dans
une partielle c'est un département qui a
voté à 71% pour un accro à l'élection
présidentielle donc on arrive avec comme
vous l'avez bien décrit donc deux
circonscriptions qui pourrait
éventuellement passer à linux du bois
les deux candidats de lannux sortante et
pour son étude sont en tête au premier
tour mais finalement
au final
les scores nous montreront sans doute
mais ça
vous nous direz peut-être ce que vous en
pensez je pense qu'on en arrivera tout
de même il y aura peut-être un député
d'acronis de moi mais ça restera un om
très largement très largement un
anachronisme on
ne refera tourner le modèle donc il a
été établi sur une base régionale parce
qu'on ne peut pas défendre au niveau des
circonscriptions mais je dirais
simplement que c'est le vrai sujet c'est
majorité absolue ou relative et quand si
majorité relative comment vont
s'organiser les soutiens parce qu'il y
aura besoin nécessairement de soutien
pour mener à bien une politique et
j'entends le président remettre en avant
l'idée de du wali own the flag du tous
derrière le président est derrière le
drapeau etc d'ailleurs il est à
l'étranger aujourd'hui là encore on
pourrait s'interroger sur la nécessité
de montrer ses dimensions
internationales du président alors que
des élections importantes ont lieu au
lieu et quel effet cela aura sur les
électeurs sur leur mobilisation ça reste
à voir et simplement comme je ne sais
plus qui disait seul n'y a pas de
substitut à la victoire cela mais la
victoire est belle 19 les sportifs et
peut-être qu'on peut rajouter qu'il ya
aussi peut-être d'une redistribution à
l'intérieur de la majorité c'est à dire
que le modem et horizons d'edouard
philippe vont prendre aussi une part
sans doute plus plus importante qu'il ne
qu'on avait les alliés des 2rm dans le
premier quinquennat un mot oui en
conclusion le dresser aux
abstentionnistes pour nous et d'aller
voter dimanche certes la fête des pères
mais
votez pour qui vous voulez mais votez
évidemment voté plus tôt pour le
candidat mais en tout cas déplacées vous
faites vous entendre et ne laissez pas
les réseaux sociaux prendre la main sur
la démocratie la vraie démocratie
participative se trouve dans les urnes
merci beaucoup merci à tous les cas
nicolas on se retrouve très vite pour
les débats justement dans les
circonscriptions de main et puis le
second tour à suivre sur moto dans les
circonscriptions des yvelines absolument
merci beaucoup à elle devra chopât merci
beaucoup vers nice 0 1 merci beaucoup
l'auront mazaury et nicolas et puis
peut-être qu'on se retrouve si vous êtes
d'accord pour se retrouver mardi
prochain pour le commentaire de deuxième
tour merci a tous rêvé
[Musique]